[Music]
your ancestors invaded macedonia and the
rest of Greece and did us harm although
we had not done you any previous injury
I have been appointed commander-in-chief
of the Greeks and it is with the aim of
punishing the Persians that I have
crossed into Asia since you are the
aggressors you gave support to the
people of paranthas who had done my
father harm and okis sent a force to
Thrace which was under our rule my
father died at the hand of conspirators
instigated by you as you yourself
boasted to everybody in your letters you
killed are seized with the help of
Burgos and gained your throne through
unjust means in defiance of Persian
custom and doing wrong to the Persians
you sent unfriendly letters to the
Greeks about me to push them to war
against me and sent money to the
Spartans and some other Greeks which
none of the other cities would accept
apart from the Spartans your invoice
corrupted my friends and sought to
destroy the peace which I established
amongst the Greeks either who led an
expedition against you and you started
the quarrel
you
but now I have defeated in battle first
your generals and satraps and now you in
person and your army and by the grace of
God's I control the country all those
who fought on your side and did not die
in battle but came over to me I hold
myself responsible for them they are not
on my side under duress but are taking
part in the expedition of their own free
will approach me therefore as the Lord
of all Asia if you are afraid of
suffering harm at my hands by coming in
person send some of your friends to
receive proper assurances come to me to
ask and receive your mother your wife
your children and anything else you wish
whatever you can persuade me to give you
shall be yours
in future whenever you communicate with
me send to me as king of Asia do not
write to me as an equal but state your
demands to the master of all your
possessions
[Music]
if not I shall deal with you as a
wrongdoer if you wish to lay claim to
the title of King then stand your ground
and fight for it do not take to flight
as I shall pursue you wherever you may
be
you